Daniel Goleman takes his ideas and concepts from his earlier book, Emotional Intelligence,...
...and he places them in the work environment in this book, "Working with Emotional Intelligence."
Leaders and successful people are not characterized by their IQs...
...or their working skills but by their emotional intelligence.
Many experts agree that emotional intelligence is the gauge with which we can measure...
...an employee's performance on basically any job.
There are twelve personal competencies to master, such as correct self-assessment,...
...initiative, optimism, self-control and so on.
In addition, there are thirteen key relationship skills, such as service orientation, conflict management and building bonds.
The author cites many instances, stories and anecdotes from large multinational companies to non-profit organizations...
...in order to illustrate how these skills and competencies can lead to success...
...or how they can actually hinder achievements.